welcome to pie mole 101 with molecular
memory in this lesson we'll learn about
the different Primal input and output
file types
and how to export a publication quality
image
in the last part we'll learn to work
with scenes one of the best ways to save
work and time let's go we'll start in
the rcsb pdb with the structure of
Carbonic anhydrase from the previous
lesson
pdb ID 3uyn
given the beautiful complex looking
structures we've seen in the first two
lessons you might be surprised to learn
that the input file type is simply a
text file
the original files were dot pdb but a
new file type called Sif has replaced
that
the details of how these files differ is
really important to a structural
biologist but a little beyond my scope
if you're interested in these nuances
though check out the video description
for a link to this pdb 101 page
explaining them
from the rcsb pdb page let's view the
Sif file for the structure
we've got some general information about
the citation first
some structural information that pymol
reads to set up the cartoon renderings
and near the end the file gives
information about the 3D coordinates of
each atom in every residue of the
structure
that's all Primal needs to create great
images
we're going to use the file we saved in
lesson two
if you didn't work through that episode
pause this video go to the video
description and copy the command line
code at the end
paste that into the command line press
enter and you'll be all caught up
now save using the drop down file menu
or by pressing Ctrl s on your keyboard
this saves a primal session file with a
DOT PSE at the end of the file name
PSE files open in Primal and can be
shared with others helping you create
images speaking of images pymol exports
PNG image files
to prep this structure for a publication
quality image we'll first change the
background
in the drop down menu display background
white
the color white is preferred because
manuscripts have a white background and
the image appears to float against it
black backgrounds also take a lot of
printer ink so back in the day when we
printed everything it was very important
to avoid black this next part is tricky
reposition the image and try to show
each and every active site sidechain
clearly
we don't want any hidden behind anything
else and we want to avoid an edge on
view like how we can't see this
tryptophan side chain here clearly
the thing we learned about in lesson one
can be helpful
scroll two fingers up and down on the
trackpad to adjust or use the scroll
wheel on a mouse
now cut off cartoon renderings look
pretty bad too so this part takes time
to get just right
okay I think this is the best I can do
with this structure now it's time to
save the PNG
we can use the file menu export image as
PNG and I get some options to choose
from
but the way I normally save is using the
external GUI buttons at the top right
click Draw slash Ray and you can adjust
the PNG to be as small or large as you
need
if you have the option to Ray this will
add a transparent background and make a
very sharp image
it gives some additional depth and makes
it look like there's a light shining on
the structure
this creates Shadows like we see right
here which may not be preferred since
there's well actually no Spotlight
within a cell
whether you choose to draw or array here
you'll get the option to save the PNG or
copy the image directly to the clipboard
which I find very useful not to be
dramatic but the day I learned to save
scenes revolutionized my pie mole
modeling experience
it is so easy to miss click and mess up
your structure and scenes give you a
quick and easy way to go back
every time I like the way a structure
looks while I'm modeling I save a scene
go to the drop down scene menu
store
select F1
the scene appears in the bottom left of
the structure viewer window
right click and rename to give your
scene a more memorable name the old
scene name appears in the upper left
hand side of the structure viewer window
delete that and let's call this active
site
now if you make a small adjustment to
the structure and you want to update the
active site scene right click and choose
update
let's change the whole rendering to see
how scenes work next to 3uyn in the
names panel action button a zoom this
zooms out to show the entire protein now
S button show as surface
rotate the protein and reorient it a
little bit
let's color it a solid color
now save a scene
drop down store F1 right click on F1 to
rename it to surface or whatever you
want
now left click on the two scene names to
toggle between them
neat you can always return to the exact
view from any scene you've saved don't
forget to control s now and save your
whole PSE session file with the new
scenes within it thanks for watching
this episode of primal 101. feel free to
leave me a comment or a question and if
you're enjoying this series subscribe to
my channel
happy modeling